we've deployed large amounts of time
money and effort
in the search for justice not good
enough
welcome to your weekly ticket we're back
baby
fresh off chloe zhao's historic win at
the academy awards kevin feige is
sharing her approach to eternals
speaking to variety feige detailed jio's
push to really fight for practical
locations and elements even in a film
full of heavy visual effects
and characters with extraordinary powers
he also went on to reveal the film's
lead
saying there were some characters that
we changed from male to female there
were some characters that we knew we
were altering from the comic books
if there was a lead in this ensemble it
is cersei played by gemma chan
and via a back to theaters teaser from
marvel studios we got a look at the
first footage from the movie from selma
hayek on horseback
to chan cersei emily v gordon and kumal
najiyani have found their next project
the couple will be working on an
adaptation of the edward gory book the
doubtful guest
it director andy musquietti who is
currently shooting dc's the flash in
london
will direct with nanjiani attached to
star the story follows a mysterious
penguin-like creature
its unannounced and unwelcome arrival at
a family's home stirs up trouble and
chaos
godzilla vs kong director adam wingard
is in talks to helm the next
monsterverse film godzilla vs kong which
debuted in the states at the end of
march has crossed 400 million dollars
globally
making it the top grossing hollywood
produced movie released since the start
of the pandemic
one title being floated around for the
sequel is son of
kong which was the sequel to the
original 1933 king kong
we're kicking off asian american pacific
islander heritage month by taking a look
at some of our
favorite aapi films in recent years
we've seen a
rise in asian american representation on
the big screen with films like crazy
rich asians
lulu wangs the farewell and of course
always be my maybe
love that film today we're talking to
editor at rotten tomatoes alex voe who
helped curate this list of rotten
tomatoes
65 best asian american movies all right
alex
what's a film from this list do you that
you think is not talked about enough
i'm gonna go with chan is missing from
1982
it's considered the first asian american
film uh it was
written directed by wayne wang um who's
asian and
it's predominantly a asian american cast
it's a comedy drama
it's about this guy who's in
he was in chinatown and he's trying to
open a taxi cab company
and his partner his name is chan he goes
missing and so he's trying to go around
town he's trying to find like where's
chan and
everybody talks to sort of has a sort of
different interpretation
of who chan is and what happened with
the money
and what's kind of interesting about it
is what you know there's a couple of
different interpretations you can have i
like roger ebert's interpretation is
that what the movie is talking
about is how everybody has different
interpretations of chan
it talks about how we sort of perceive
asian americans through
fictions how we see them through movies
or talented or
only really known through like you know
getting food at restaurants
so it's an interesting way of sort of
having
americans sort of take in their
interpretation of how we see
outsiders or people who don't look like
us i can't believe the first asian
american film came out in 82
yeah that's so like that's too recent
yeah and i think it costs like ooh like
20 000 to make a shot oh my god
yeah yeah i think a lot of like san
francisco university students are in it
um yeah but it's trip like if you like
jim john moosh movies
um you'll you'll vibe to this for sure
well there's
a lot of john cho films on this list uh
he makes four appearances
on the list what are your favorites that
show off his range
searching which is the thriller where
it's a one-man show where he's
in front of a computer and he's just
trying to find
his daughter i think that's really
impressive i think what's interesting
about his career
is sort of like you know you first saw
him as like
the milf guy from american pie
you know and that's how good a
performance is like he could do he could
turn down to a career
he's got range yeah and then you know
and it's so rare
really to see an asian american actor
where you kind of see him
mature and evolve you know next you want
to you did a better luck tomorrow
year after that he's like you know a
college stoner or post-college stoner in
um
hirono kumar and then like you know 10
years later now he's like a dad and a
thriller
it's kind of a gift to be able to show
off that range
and yeah it's cool that he he
experimented with such a unique
style of film too right yeah exactly
yeah now
you have written a personal essay about
rotten tomatoes what's something you
think that
people should know about how rotten
tomatoes has changed over the years
so the first thing i wanted to talk
about in this essay
is that it was founded by asian
americans
and it's an asian-american story and i
have sort of really it's a really
positive story and i think it was sort
of important to sort of talk about that
um in this moment um one was one of the
interesting things
in regards to how we sort of now talk
about movies as you know
sanduang who was the founder or
co-founder of ron tomatoes
you know in 1999 you know that was when
ron paul employees first started getting
invited to screenings so sam shows up
to watch um the haunting that
we made that horror remake with the liam
neeson and
the studio guy goes like this is fake
you don't belong here you know and he
got kicked out
and for him and to speak to his
character
he resolved like the reason i got kicked
out was because
online critics were seen as second-class
citizens
and his reaction to that was you know
what i'm going to put
more online critics onto me or
instrument tomatoes because you know you
saw
rocks without any possible way to
champion those voices so i mean really
like
what's changed is like now we don't even
think about the difference between
online critics or a newspaper critic
you know and through his actions over
time
we kind of got to that point and that's
a really cool story yeah it's it's not
about
you know where the voice is coming from
it's just the voice itself so
exactly it's craigslist it doesn't need
to be from your paper it could be from
online wherever wherever
you need to communicate through
everyone's going to get a voice in and
we're going to get to hear them all and
it's going to be
yeah that's great love it all right well
thank you for coming on the show alex so
where can people find you you can find
me on a website called
rottentomatoes.com that's where i sort
of live and breathe
all right i think i got that one i'll
see you i'll see you there too man
available to watch in theaters on friday
is wrath of man
need to know is responsible i'll kill my
son
mysterious and wild eyed a new security
guard for a cash truck surprises his
co-workers when he unleashes precision
skills during a heist
the crew is left wondering who he is and
where he came from
soon the marksman's ultimate motive
becomes clear as he takes dramatic and
irrevocable steps
to settle a score the film is directed
by guy richie and stars jason statham
halt mcalleny and scott eastwood
available to watch on voodoo is
mainstream
are you prepared to let the world see
the real you
he's not who he says he is in mainstream
a young woman played by maya hawk thinks
she's found a path to internet stardom
when she starts making youtube videos
with a charismatic stranger played by
andrew garfield
that is of course until the dark side of
viral celebrity threatens to ruin them
both
the film is written and directed by gia
coppola alright everyone well that's it
for today but before you go leave us a
comment and let us know what you'll be
watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time